24時間
橋の上生活
[音楽]
えっこんにちはですというわけで今来て
おりますのはこちら
静岡県の三島市にある三島スカイウォーク
という400mほどあるでっけえ橋で
ございますなんと三島スカイウォーク日本
一大きい人道橋人が渡る橋ですつまり車と
かが通る橋を除くと日本一大きい橋です来
たことあるもう初めてかもしれない初めて
です
か
健介の故郷
はじめさんは初めてなんですか
ねもう10年以上いますけど名前をよく
聞くのよ有名でいろんな観光客の方が来
られるのも知ってるけど来たのは初めてだ
ねもうすぐオープンでお客さんが普通に
来るんですけど
めっちゃ
揺れましたちょっと揺らしてみていい
入れる入れるでしょ入れる
[音楽]
大丈夫それという感じめっちゃ奥まで続い
てるわけじゃないですけども今日はそんな
スカイ
ウォークで24時間生活したいと思います
まあまあまああるよねこういうことないよ
ねもし仮に両サイド的に挟まれて動けなく
なって
耐久戦だみたいに24時間待つぞみたいな
戦国時代一言あるかもしれないんですよ
塞がられて出れなくなった時に生活できる
のかどうかってサバイバル力をつけたん
ですねよくありますいつも通り
サイコロールはありですか3時間ごとに1
回よしよしよしよし3時間2回サイコロ
振って出た目に応じて何かができるって事
ねはい
ちなみにここクズオープンなのでそろそろ
一般のお客さんも来られるということで
結構気まずい感じにはなると思います
ちゃんと許可を取って撮影しております皆
さんは絶対真似しないでくださいはいはい
生活って書いてあるじゃん24時間生活
ってことは基本的に何でもしていいって
ことだよね生活は基本的にはじゃあ寝てい
いってことでこうやっても
24時間あるんでまぁ結局寝る時間も必要
ですねそうだよねネタに食ったりも強いあ
食ったりは
ぐったりはまあ24時間なんで
サイコロでいきましょう
常に食えるわけじゃないからねサバイバル
ですか食べ物もサイコロ次第ってことか
今日曇り空で結構
太陽出てたら苦しかったんですけども割と
程よい気候でなんとかいけるかと思います
サイコロ3時間後にまた確認しましょう
じゃあ早速やっていきたいと思います
ちょっと9時になりましたねちょっと9時
になりました今日の朝9時から明日の朝9
時まで俺はもうこの橋から動きません
なくなってしまいますお願いしますお疲れ
お疲れ様です
たくさん人が来ますねすごい人気
橋が
めっちゃ揺れますね
橋の上でしょ
意外と余裕だと思うんすよねちょっと
のんびりさせていただきたいと思います
[音楽]
はいあの暇ですせっかく来たので奥まで
行ってみたいと思います
いやーすごいな
奥行きがちょっと太陽が出てきたかなって
いう気もしますいや高いところ苦手なんだ
けど
箸とか絶対崩れないでしょ感あるところは
大丈夫なんだよねだからね割と今生きれ
ますそんな怖くないです
[音楽]
すごいです橋の奥まで来るとピタッと風が
止みましたすごいなこんなに強いんだ
[音楽]
こっち痛いな
端っこまで来ました
ここがゴールですね
戻ろう
[音楽]
お疲れ様です1時間経過しましたこれね
きついわすごい人が通るんですけど
馬鹿揺れるんですよやばくない結構入れる
でしょ真ん中行ったらすごいの揺れが今
割と橋のねちょっと
端っこの方にいるんですけど
揺れるしちょっと太陽も出てきて暑いし風
は強くてなんかちょっと寒いし結構悪魔的
な苦しさを感じてるね俺はこれずっとこう
いう感じなんですよ今日いやなんか生活な
んで必要なものあればご飯以外だと言って
もらえればある程度のものは持ってきます
じゃあ寝たくなったら布団とかもなるほど
常にね
震度2が来てる感じなのに結構やばくない
ちょっと早急に俺はもう降りたいまで
スマホとか
立たないもん
[音楽]
じゃあ2時間目頑張ります
お疲れ様です3時間経ちました
そのねー
観光客がすごい大勢いらっしゃるので変な
ことできないというそのちょっと真面目
ぶっちゃってますこれずっとここでこう
本当にこれぐらいしか移動しかないから
生活というよりなんか南京みたいなかなり
あの今ちょっとお客さんが多いので
大人しくしてますちょっと我慢の時間だね
あ3時間経ったからってことねなるほど
えーと1
位やばいね14以外333ちょっとお昼な
ので3欲しいです僕3お願いします行き
ます
落ちたらどうしよう箸から
低めに行ってはい
[音楽]
ということで2話
酔い止めです
1個言って結構ね頭痛いんですよ
わかるこの
嫌な揺れずっと続いてる気持ち悪いです
Youtuber出てる人こんにちは
見てるありがとう
痛み止めじゃなくて
酔い止めから正直助かります
あのねほんと今3時間経過するわけでしょ
3時間ずっと揺れてるの結構ね気持ち悪い
のはもちろんなんですけど
めまいがして
いい意味でしんどいです
[音楽]
酔い止めまじで助かります水なしでいける
やつねいただきますうわサイダー味なの
ありが
てーってことでしょ
貴重なお昼ご飯いただきます
あと3時間頑張りますいつ持ってき
ましょうかあそうだねちょっと休みたい
ところあるのでお昼休憩がてらにちょっと
座らせてください特別な許可を頂いて
ちょっと置かせていただいてます絶対真似
しないでくださいねあー助かる
助かるけど多分通行の邪魔になりたくない
ので極力よってちょっとこういう感じで3
時間過ごしますねお願いしますね
揺れる
[音楽]
ガチで行かれてるわ
はいお昼ぐらいですねなんかほんとここに
座ってるのがかなり申し訳ないんですけど
もなんかいろんな人に声をかけていただい
て
笑顔で言ってくれてありがたいですすごい
申し訳ないこんなとこにいるの変だもん
頑張ります
[音楽]
お疲れ様です
6時間経過しました
寒い風がずっと強いから体力が奪われすぎ
て
途中からもう丸まっていかに体温を下げ
ないかの戦いになっちゃうからこれやばい
わそっちの辛さか風ですねできますお願い
します風が強すぎるからできれば5番の
段ボールもありあとすごい寂しいので友達
来るのもあり誰が来るかは知らないです
けどもご飯も食べたいです体温を上げたい
結構これね
命かかってます
行きます
[音楽]
飯が良かった
まあでも
友達が来るよって書いてあるこれ友達誰
来るのこれいや友達誰来る誰来るのこれ
おーい
[音楽]
どれぐらい行ってくれるんですかこれまあ
最後まで
と言いたいところですけど次のサイコロ
まで3時間くらいかおもろいのがやっぱ
海外の人とか多いから
初めて社長って知らないで写真撮ってって
言われて写真撮ってるのマジおもろいです
けどね
ありがとうございます3時間ほどいて
くれるとほんと
もちろんですしばらくサービスが一緒にい
てくれます
[音楽]
はい17時になりましたどうですか
寒いです寒いよね
寒いめっちゃ寒いです多分ね俺の方が寒い
ねただこれで17時になったのでこの橋に
はもうお客さんが来られなくなったので
ここからは
貸し切りです
あと1時間ぐらいやるからさどうせだっ
たらこの歳じゃ使って遊ぼうぜ
遊びましょう
クリコだなくなりそうだね
[笑い]
俺もここ出たら
企画失敗だからね
400mグリコ
どんぐらいかかるかちょっとマジでやって
みようあと1時間時間計っときますじゃあ
スタート最初はグーじゃんけんぽん最高
でしょあいこでしょよしよしよしよしこれ
言葉何ですかあれ
パイナップルグリコチョコレート
色々あるじゃないです
他に何があるのグーはグリコじゃないです
かパイナップル
チョコレートか
チョコはチョコレートとか
マジで怖いあれなんかあったっすよねいや
ないないない全くないグリコこれのみか
すいませんでした日本
短くて最近帰ってきたのでじゃあパーで
買ったの行きます
パイナップル全然見てみまだ
じゃんけんぽんほらもうマジでマジで余裕
見えなくなっちゃう
じゃんけんぽんあいこでしょ
もうきつくない結構スペシャル
じゃんけんぽん何パーマ
チョキ
横横
えもうやばいよ
ちゃんとやれよ
じゃんけんぽん
グー
ようやくね
いつもいいよ
[音楽]
勝率やばくない
のよこれコールドゲームあるぞマジで
じゃんけんぽんグー
[音楽]
じゃんけんぽん
チョキじゃんけんぽん
チョキじゃんけんぽん長期じゃんけんぽん
グー
逆転ある距離になってきたぞ
じゃんけんぽんグー来てる来てる
じゃんけんぽん
グーディコここで
チョキ出します
じゃんけんぽん
たリスト入ってます
[音楽]
じゃんけんぽん
チョキ
と安心するとねパターン見えるのよ
じゃんけんぽん
じゃんけんぽんグー
チョキあいこでしょ
チョキ
ちょっと
ごめんと
さっきより開いてない
ちゃんとやってくれ
[音楽]
パイナップル
ぽいねまだ半分
[音楽]
じゃんけんぽん長期
血よこれいとありがとうございました勝ち
ましたこれは多分あれですね
普通のじゃんけんと違ってオッズが違う
から何の話してんの橋で
ありがとう400m
走でやったら30分ぴったりぐらい31分
かかってますね
面白かったね
面白かったじゃあ戻りますはいもうすぐ9
時間経過しようとしてるんですけれども雨
がめっちゃ降ってきました俺この中で今日
寝るの
余裕9時間経過しました
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
段ボール出たら死ぬから普通に
濡れちゃう
よ行きます痛い
飯食いて
すごいスピンするし
[音楽]
また呼ばれると思わなかったです3時間
頑張っていきたいと思います
[音楽]
やめこれはい気合で雨晴らしましたさっき
まで大雨だったのでちょっと一瞬どうなる
かと思ったんですけどもまあこれが神です
天候なんて本当あの朝飯前な操るの何かや
もう9時間は経ってるのであと3時間で
半分でしょうまあ生きるでしょういや
良かった雨止んで結構普通にね雨降った時
も帰ろうと思ったんですけどなんとか耐え
てますねはいまだ行けますそしてここから
は日が暮れてくるのできっと寒くなってき
ます風がマジでやばいんでサイコロのダン
ボールとかはマジで当てたいかなと思って
おります
頑張ります
寒いんですよ皆さんこれ何も考えられない
ぐらい実は寒いです
[音楽]
塗るか楽しみです
お腹は減ったし寒い寝れるわけなかろう
[音楽]
[拍手]
ありがとうございましたちょっと寒すぎる
のでヒートテックとか暖かい服を買ってき
てもらったのにちょっと来ますこれね普通
に遭難だねもう
雪山の山
寒すぎ
あーいける
わ違うこれいけるね
やばい寒いマジで無理もう本当にやだ帰り
たい
[音楽]
[拍手]
まずいまずい
無理マジ寒い本当に
[音楽]
というわけで12時間経過しました
半分行きましたありがとうございました
ありがとうございました
ありがとうございますけど
寒いもう
止まってらんないぐらい寒いですヒート
テック来てても全然寒いぐらい気温が
かなり寒いのと
橋の真ん中だからなのもあると思うんです
けどもめちゃくちゃ風が強くて普通にもう
手が悴んで動かなくなってますここでなん
としてもサイコロでご飯か段ボールがない
と
死にます
健介が
一発で決めますお願いします
もう
止まってるよねやったーメシだ
[音楽]
お腹すきましたがもうねー
太陽の下がりすぎてマジで無理もうご飯
ざっくり書いてるんですけどどうやって
決めるんですかもしかしたら
毎回毎回3が出るかなと思って
ルーレット準備してありますルーレット
ありがとうございます
なるほど少ないのもあるということかま
けど基本的にいい
量だけどたまにおかしいな表記もありま
すって感じか気分的には何食べたいですか
正直寒すぎて何でも書き込みたい気分いや
危なかった本当にこれなかったら一発勝負
ですよねもちろんお願いします行きます
はい
ストップ
俺がオーダーまさか
ありがとう食べれないよりか全然いいただ
多分橋の上でキング牛丼食うやつ世界初の
気がしてきましたこれ買ってきてもらえる
んですか
ありがとうございますちょっと
蜂の真ん中が普通に危険すぎるので風が足
のもうちょっと奥の方行ってみようかと
思いますはいというわけで今お昼ご飯あ
違った
マジでやばい今ご飯買いに行ってもらっ
てる最中なんですけれども皆さんご覧
ください夜景がめっちゃ綺麗なんですこれ
[音楽]
わかるかなすごい綺麗なのよ夜景がいや
もう気づいたら半日12時間ここにいる
わけでしょ結構精神的に苦しいのとやっぱ
風が強いから体力超取られてるんでここで
しっかり食べてあと12時間
頑張りたいと思います
[音楽]
お待たせいたしました
来ましたか
遅くなってすみません
いいねちょうどなんかちょっと遅めの
夜ご飯みたいな時間になりましたまずは
目が一つと目が2つでこれでキング牛丼の
量ということですねはいいいんですか
いただいていやもう是非
半分入れますいや1日分だって今日何にも
食べないかもしれないじゃないですか24
時間明日の朝まで持たないといけないから
ね多分ご飯食べなさすぎて体温が下がっ
てるのよこれがまたね
牛丼食べたくなっちゃうよね
是非食べてあったまってください
いただきます三島スカイウォークでご飯
食べるのダメなんですよちょっと食べれ
ないのでいや待ってください特別に許可を
もらって食べていいとのことな
橋の上は飲食禁止なので皆さん絶対に真似
しないでください本当に特別な許可を
もらって今回撮影させていただいており
ます感謝
いただきます三島スカイウォークの
従業員の皆様に感謝うちさんに感謝の
お母さんに
おいおいおいおい
やめてって言われるの俺だからやめて
[音楽]
これはねこの
橋に12時間
程度にしか分かんないやつだ
染み渡るね
[音楽]
肉は
良かった
まあ11時帰るんで
ゆっくり
12時までに食べれないとどうなります
12時までに食べれなくても大丈夫です
大丈夫ですはい全然食べて大丈夫です12
時まで食べないと
没収とかないんですかさすがにそんな
せっかく出してもらったんですみません
募集というと全部食べていただいて明日の
9時になるところ
頑張りますマジで
[音楽]
やっぱでも何も食べてなかったからお腹
空いてましたお腹空いてる
ガチでメガでちょうど良かったです
[音楽]
[笑い]
あとちょっとがマジでキツイキングはあと
こんだけなのには
食べようナイス
ごちそうさまでしたありがとうございまし
たはいというわけで食事も無事に終わって
今11時前ですね寝床はあるんですけども
あの寝袋とかではなくガチの布団みたいな
感じで寝ていきたいと思います冷めない
これそこはちょっともう12時のサイコロ
で
なんとかするしかないなダンボールで風を
ガードするか1出してちょっと動いてから
だった止めるからちょっとベッド
メイキングしていきたいと思います
[音楽]
はい布団が完成しましたもう意味わかんな
すぎますこれ
箸の上ですなかなか見ない光景ですけども
今日はここで寝ていきたいと思いますもう
すぐ11時になりますちょっと体力が
かなりやばいのでとりあえず布団に入ろう
かと思いますこの状況
[音楽]
寝れるわけねえよこんなのこういうところ
で寝てます
濡れるのめっちゃ怖いんだけど
[音楽]
ちょっと調べよう
大丈夫だクマはいないでしょじゃあ寝れる
よ
[音楽]
やばい
自然が怖くて寝れねえさっきタヌキいた
もんたぬきいたしクマ出てきたら俺普通に
もう終わりよここで動画俺本当にこれ24
時間生きれないのかなめっちゃ怖いんだ
けど普通におやすみ
[音楽]
なのでなんとかします
寒い
雨が降ってきたぞ
あれあーだるいよ
12時12時かサイコロかはい
雨降っててさやばいのよ結構普通に
ダンボール欲しいからなるほど行きます
[音楽]
4は
マジで
[音楽]
18時間経過しました
野生の生き物の声も聞こえるし風邪寒いし
これは夜寝るもんじゃないですねそれは
そうというわけで深夜3時の最後のタイム
やっていきたいと思います
[音楽]
酔い止めです
ちょっとね気持ち悪いから
ギリセーフ
助かる
いただきます
6時にお会いしましょうありがとう
おやすみ
雨がやばい
はい20時間経過しました
朝5時です
一睡もできませんでした
布団が寝袋じゃないとかもあると思うん
ですけども人の寝る環境ではないことが
はっきり分かりましたねあと雨もきつかっ
たですもうめっちゃ冷たくて起きちゃった
し風もずーっと強くて目をつむって何とか
しんどいだりして気づいたら朝になって
ましたあと4時間です今日はちょっと曇
りっぽいですね
太陽出てたぐらいの方が暖かくて助かると
思うんですけどもまさかのもうほぼ7月な
のに寒さとの戦いということでもう
ちょっと頑張っていきたいと思います1
時間後にサイコロ振ります
無理無理無理無理マジで顔無理なんだけど
めっちゃ香るやんけありがとうございます
6時になりましたさあ残すことあと3時間
橋の上ってのは思ったより苦しい生活でし
たもうね風が強い山の上にあるからかも
しれないんですけど風が超強くて目がし
なかったんですけどなんとか耐え忍びで
残り3時間まで来ましたあと3時間気合で
持ちこたえたいと思いますラストダイス
ロール一発勝負で行かせていただきます俺
はもうこの位置に全てをかける行きます
[音楽]
起きるかどうもラスト1時間切りました
最後はあのサイコロが無しだったので
せっかくこんな素晴らしい
環境を独り占めできるのであればこの日本
一で橋の真ん中で動画編集したりネタ考え
たら色々思い浮かぶのかなと思って
ちょっと最後の1時間はそういう時間にし
たいと思います
捗るかな色々今当たっててなんか前よりて
きそうな気がするのでちょっと考えます
[音楽]
あと30分ぐらいで
何も思い浮かん
[音楽]
地面だ
お疲れ様でしたお疲れ様でした
すごいなぁ
[音楽]
ここに24時間やったのね
これが日本一大きい人道強化いやでも
やっぱりしっかりした作りだったんで
グァンガン揺れる恐怖とかなかったんです
けどもやっぱり揺れはしたんでそれが24
時間続いたのと夜は風がすごかったんです
ね
温泉行きたいっす
[音楽]